[Music]
From now on, I want to take one picture each day and
leave it with a few words.
It
turns out that each day spent with the one I love is more precious than anything
So I want to build up memories little by little like this
A
secret diary of just the two of
us is green 2 nasa You don't like that kind of thing
No, I think it's really good
The secret between just the two of us makes me feel a little excited It's
certainly a great idea It's actually a great idea to record memories in detail with photos Rather, it's only possible in this day and age It's
important, so let's
look forward to Tsukasa-chan
[Music
] Well,
I don't really know what this
is, but
ah, it's the first time I've
ever had a number of grants.
[Music]
Today's
photo is Shuhei.